PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Are
you spending more time
monitoring your services
than developing new ones?
Find out how you can
use Anthos to improve
the observability
of your services
and become more productive.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Priyanka, and
welcome to Anthos 101.
Software is revolutionizing
every industry.
It doesn't matter if your
company sells tires, delivers
pizza, is a bank, or helps
recruit new employees.
Software is now a key
part of what you deliver.
So let's look at how
you can use Anthos
to be productive while
keeping your customers happy.
Anthos gives you access to a
service operations dashboard
that greatly simplifies
what it takes
for you to keep
your applications up
and running at peak
efficiency to serve
those wonderful
customers of yours.
Key to making this happen are
what we call golden signals.
If you can only
measure four metrics
of your user-facing systems,
focus on, first, latency,
which is the time it takes
to service a request.
It's important to distinguish
between the latency
of successful requests and the
latency of failed requests.
Second is traffic, which is
the measure of how much demand
is being placed on
your system measured
in high-level,
system-specific metrics.
Third is errors, which
are the rate of requests
that fail, either explicitly--
for example, HTTP
500s; implicitly--
example, HTTP 200
success responses
but coupled with the wrong
content; or by policy--
example, if you committed to
one-second response times,
any request over one
second is an error.
And fourth, saturation, which
is how full your service is,
a measure of your
system fraction
emphasizing the resources
that are most constrained.
These golden signals
are the cornerstone
of establishing and
embracing SRE best
practices at your organization.
If you are looking into
adopting these methodologies,
the service mesh should
be your solution.
So what is a service mesh?
A service mesh provides
a transparent and
language-independent
way to flexibly
and easily automate
application network functions.
And it is a foundational
component of Anthos.
Anthos Service Mesh helps
you monitor and manage
service interactions across all
your different environments.
Adopting micro services
has lots of benefits,
like increasing
velocity and scaling.
But it also adds complexity.
If different teams own
each of these components,
how do you track the total
latency for that transaction
or ensure that traffic between
these services is secure?
As an operator, you
have a tough job
to do in order to
give your customers
the amazing experience
they deserve.
Anthos Service
Mesh brings to you
a topology view of all the
services deployed in the mesh.
You can see what's
running, who calls whom,
and metrics for
each interaction.
Anthos Service Mesh
generates these metrics
without any changes
to your application
by tracking all communications
between your services.
On a single screen, it
becomes easy for you
as an administrator to spot
problems and see metrics,
including all four of the
golden signals we talked about.
But also, you can
go as deep as needed
with detailed information
at the per-node level,
including CPU and memory usage.
These metrics help
your app developers
as they look to do
performance tuning
for the services they own.
This is very useful to
you as operators too.
Anthos Service Mesh lets
you set Service Level
Objectives against
any of these generated
metrics we talked about.
And once you set
up this SLO, you
can immediately see how
the service is performing.
And once you have SLOs, you can
start managing your deployment
risk using error budgets.
This enables you to catch
problems early and fix them
well before your
customers run into them.
What makes this so
powerful is that now you
can break down the problem of
keeping your deployment running
into smaller, more
manageable pieces,
reducing operational complexity.
Anthos Service Mesh also
gathers all logs and traces
for your services, bringing
them together into one place.
Generally, you might have
one system for metrics,
one system for logs, and
something else for tracing.
So correlating between them
is difficult or impossible.
Anthos helps you bring
them all together.
There you have it.
With Anthos, you can
adopt SRE best practices
and improve your observability
using golden signals.
Try Anthos Service Mesh and
the Observability Dashboard
following the links below.
And for more Anthos
content, don't
forget to subscribe and check
out the entire Anthos 101
playlist.
[MUSIC PLAYING]